what we're going to do in this video is
get some practice writing reasonably
large numbers in different ways
so for example let's say we had this
number and i'm going to not say it out
loud on purpose so
this number right over here what i want
to do is think about how would i write
this out in words and i encourage you to
pause this video and try to figure that
out on your own before we do it together
and actually take out paper and actually
write this out what would you how would
you write this number
well now we can do it together and
actually before i even write it out in
words i'll write this out in a place
value table because it might help us or
it just helps us break down exactly what
this number represents
so just as a bit of a refresher if
you're not familiar with place value
tables you think of a column for the
different place values and here we're
going from the ones place all the way
the tens hundreds thousands ten
thousands so we're going to have a ten
thousands
place right over here
we're going to have a thousands place
right over here
and this is just an s here so ten
thousands one thousands sometimes you'll
see it written out this is
the hundreds
place this is the tens
place and this is the ones place
and so how many ten thousands do we have
actually let's start at the ones place
how many ones do we have we see it right
there we have five ones
how many tens do we have we see it right
there actually we have zero tens
how many hundreds do we have we see it
right there six hundreds
how many thousands we go to the
thousands place and we see we have two
thousands
and then how many ten thousands we have
well we see right there we have eight
ten thousands
so now let's now that we have this
representation let's write it out in
words and you don't have to do this
every time but i'm just trying to make
sure we see every possible way of
thinking about it
so you could say eight tens two
thousands six hundreds and five ones but
that's not exactly how people would say
it out in words what is typical is that
people would say 82 thousands
605
and so i'm going to write it that way
and when you write on words the the
standard way of doing it is actually put
commas wherever you would put the commas
in this is right over here written in
standard form so what we would do is we
would express this part right over here
as 82 000. so let me write it out
80
82 82 000
thousand
and then put this comma there
82 000 comma and then we have
600 and then we have no tens so it's
605. if there was a 110 here that would
have been 615 but this is just 605
and so i will do it in
a different color let's do it in this
blue color so 82 000 and then six
hundred
six
hundred
five
and we're done
let's do another example
so now i'm gonna write out a number in
words and i want you to write it in
standard form so the number is
fifty
thousand
fifty
thousand
six
hundred
six hundred
thirty
31
30
1 and i want you to write this in
standard form so it's really just write
it out as a number and put commas in the
appropriate places pause this video and
see if you can do that
all right now let's do it together
so this first part 50 000
well we could just write that as
actually let's put the place values out
here so this is the ten thousands place
this is thousands place hundreds tens
and ones so fifty thousand
so fifty thousands you could write like
this you could say that's five ten
thousands or you could say this is fifty
thousands
then they say six hundred thirty one
so
600 well that's 600s right over here and
then 31
that is 30 and 1 or 3 tens and 1 1. 3
tens in 1 1 or 31 and of course you want
to put your comma in the same place and
you put your comma every three places so
the first time you do it if you're
moving from the right you put it between
the hundreds and the thousands place so
there you have it this is the same thing
as fifty thousand six hundred and thirty
one this is that number written in
standard form